- Hello.
You guys are cute!
Walking out here with
your hats and your whole,
you are very cool, rock and roll country.
I'm into it.
- Oh my goodness, thank you.
- And congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Yes, such an exciting time.
Love is blooming.
I heard that a dog introduced y'all.
Is that, can I meet the dog?
Maybe it can help me.
- It is actually the, like a funny story
'cause I was walking out of an audition
on the Sunset Gala in Hollywood.
And Billy's dog at the time, Tex,
who was the most beautiful
German shepherd you've ever seen.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- He was tapped into some divine purpose
because we were, you know,
at the time just friends
and all these years later,
that was like 14 years ago.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So yeah, all these years
later we just got married.
- I love dogs.
(audience clapping)
They're the best.
So wait, so I love your accent.
I love Australia as well.
Sorry, I'm focusing on her.
I'm just like, just for a minute.
No, I just, I love Australia so much.
So what, what made you wanna move here?
- Honestly, Kelly, I had this
weird desire my whole life
that was like this burning
desire to come to America.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I can't even explain where it came from
except pop music was like my spirituality.
I just felt like this calling
when I listened to a song,
your songs, which I'm trying
to not completely freak out,
but like...
- You are keeping it cool,
ma'am, yeah, you are totally.
- You're one of my absolute idols.
- Oh thanks.
- And listening to your music
growing up in Australia,
I just like literally felt this calling
that I just knew in my spirit
that I belonged in America.
- It's a purpose.
Yeah.
- At 19 I just got on a
plane and never looked back.
Like, yeah.
- I did the same thing like 18.
I drove and everyone was
like, what are you doing?
But I drove from Texas to LA
and just lived on a mattress and worked.
'Cause I knew, I was like,
this has gotta be it.
There's no backup plan.
I hope it works.
- Literally.
- Yeah.
I was like, there's no backup plan.